bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur TVFI
78 il est l'heure de parler sport le 78
sport c'est avec Anthony r comme chaque
lundi bonsoir Anthony bonsoir wilfreine
dans cette édition du 78 sport
évidemment tous les résultats du weekend
mais nous parlerons aussi roller roquet
je recevrai les chocks des lancour les
joueurs de Benjamin Ferran ont obtenu
leur ticket pour la Nationale 2 lors des
phases finales il y a 10 jours mais tout
d'abord place aux femmes et au basket
évidemment après avoir fêté la la montée
en National une avec son public ce
weekend une partie de l'équipe de
l'Entente le chîn Versailles sera
présente sur le plateau pour revenir sur
cette saison quasi parfaite Wilfried et
on va commencer par le basket justement
oui tout à fait après avoir fait avoir
trôné toute la saison quasiment en tête
de la Nationale 2 un bilan exceptionnel
qui leur a permis d'accrocher les
play-offs et à deux journées de la fin
de la phase finale valider leur ticket
pour la montée en National une sur le
parquet de Furdenheim à l'extérieur ce
weekend les joueuses de l'Entente le
chîn et Versailles retrouvaiit leur
public pour fêter cette montée qui
fuyait le club depuis 2000 fallait-il
encore gagner pour ne rien gâcher récit
avec Julie Rocha Soarez quand le pivot
Cécile dancer marque le premier panier
du match on se dit alors que la
rencontre face à sain saavine ne sera
qu'une formalité mais surprise par
l'activité championnoise à l'extérieur
les joueuses de l'Entente le chînet
Versailles en manque de réussite au tir
et peut-être déjà la tête à la fête
d'après match se font distancer 2129
après 10 minutes de jeu
dans les 2è et 3è quartemps les
versaillaises plus rigoureuses en
défense grignotent leur retard pour
finalement prendre la tête d'un petit
point
5655 au prix d'un 4è cartant de feu les
ivelinoises arrachent la prolongation
dans un gymnase du B en ébullition 67
partout mais dans cette première période
supplémentaire de 5 minutes elles
prennent des shoots difficiles et ne
trouvent pas la solution dans la
raquette sain saavine s'impose
finalement 7571 et devrait accompagner
le LCV en National 1 la saison prochaine
les coéquipièr de Chantal descoin perd
de invincibilité dans les playoff après
qu victoires en autant de rencontre mais
cette défaite ne gâche absolument pas la
fête c'est vrai que c'est dommage de de
terminer en plus devant notre public sur
sur une défaite on voulait vraiment
gagner ce soir et fêter cette montée en
National avec notre public mais écoutez
c'est comme ça et on va aller chercher
maintenant la première place du
championnat et j'espère qu'on va
l'avir nous avons très bien travaillé
toute la
saison nous sommes restés vraiment
soud et on mérite d'aller en National
1 la National une les filles de vin
Bardic la retrouvons 13 ans après
l'avoir quitté mais sans leur coach qui
met fin à sa carrière d'entraîneur mais
il lui reste un dernier défi ramener le
titre de champion de France de tour les
8 et 9 juin
prochain VO belle victoire belle saison
et ces joueuses qui sont venu en plateau
vous l'avit promis
son plusieurs semaines pas pour moi pour
les téléspectateurs mais c'est vrai
qu'elles sont là c'est très très bonsoir
à vous bonsoir toutes les on va
commencer à droiteinie bonsoir à vous
leuse ala bonsoir et évidemment ce sont
des bas je confirme elles sont très très
grandesout on peut faire un plan large
je vais être très très petit en fait
donc je vais rester ass on est mieux
c'est vrai qu'elles sont assez grandes
évidemment alors on vient de voir le
sujet on était là ce weekend pour pour
cette belle fête que vous avez vous vous
avez communier avec votre public c'est
important et c'était une belle fête ce
weekend justement du côté du chînet OUI
effectivement donc on avait à cœur de
remercier le public d'être venu pendant
toute la saison nous
supporter malheureusement on n pas
remporter le match puisqu'on a perdu
après prolongation mais ça a quand même
été une belle fête puisqu'on a pu
justement communier avec le public à la
fin leur faire une petite danse pour les
remercier également et puis il y avait
un pot donc qui était offert par le club
pour remercier également les supporters
donc ça a été une belle fête qui s'est
terminée jusque tard dans la nuit vous
aviez trop répété la fête la
chorégraphie pour la danse et du coup
vous êtes passé à côté du match oui
effectivement je pense qu'on avait déjà
la tête un peu à la fête ou au final
fort puisque on va jouer le titre pour
être champion de France donc c'est pas
qu'on a laissé échapper le match mais
c'est vrai qu'on était beaucoup plus
libéré et beaucoup moins investi pendant
tout tout le match Virginie vous me
tendez un petit peu la perche puisque la
chorégraphie on on en avait un petit peu
parlé on l'a bien observé d'ailleurs je
vous propose de regarder encore un petit
extrait parce je que vous allez leur
demander de le faire en plateau non
quand même pas on va pas leur redemander
ça mais je crois que il y avait quand
même un petit peu des petits problèmes
de synchronis pendant cette Coré non un
petit peu oui voir les images ouis on va
essayer de voir les images un petit peu
si si les images sont
là voil vous pouvez les commenter
hésitez pas la première ligne ça va à
peu près surtout pas me
regarder effectivement on s'était juste
entraîné quelques minutes jeudi après
l'entraînement donc on s'était on voyait
la vidéo sur Facebook mais voilà c'était
plus un moment convivial on n pas toutes
des danseuses confirmé donc donc on a
fait avec les moyens du bord c'est
important justement de de voilà de
marquer un peu le coup pour le public
ben oui c'était aussi le moyen de leur
faire une petite surprise puisque
personne s'attendait à ce que on fasse
une danse donc il pisait après la
défaite mais bon voilà ça permettait de
continuer un peu plus la fête donc
c'était assez sympathique alors leilla
sur cette saison qui était plutôt
excellente en tête toute la saison
régulière vous validez votre ticket de
journées avant la fin des play-offs
qu'est-ce qui a fait la force de
l'équipe cette saison qui avait un un
effectif assez restreint au final un
effectif certes restreint mais euh
vraiment soudé et vraiment soudé du
début je dirais jusqu'à aujourd'hui
encore et j'espère jusqu'au titre et
puis remporter le titre souder oui
souder que ce soit sur le terrain et à
l'extérieur du terrain on a fait pas mal
de de de sorties entre copines et du
coup je pense
que ça y joue beaucoup sur le terrain et
alors vous avez eu des renforts de choix
qui sont juste derrière vous la personne
d'Alena et de gorit je va poser une
petite question à Elena qu'on connait
pas trop parce on l'a pas vu dans le
sujet cé TR
mon est votre sentiment quel est votre
sentiment après cette saison avec
l'Entente
versaill je suis très
heureuses
emble nétait pas juste pour monter voilà
on mérite la monter en par beaucoup de
travail notamment
avec trs heure je suis très heureuse et
surtout
déstessette
validation l'objectif maintenant
évidemment c'est vraiment la montée et
le titre de champion de France Merci
Alena et alors justement on va en parler
de ce titre de champion de France he
parce qu'il était peut-être aussi un peu
dans la tête samedi soir en outre outre
la fête puisque vous allez jouer le
titre Les les 8 et 9 juin prochain du
côté de tour c'est le deuxè objectif
outre la montée ben oui je pense que
c'est comme on dit souvent la cerise sur
le gâteau ça serait vraiment voilà ce
qui permettrait de terminer en beauté
cette saison puisque au-delà d'avoir été
première toute la saison dans notre
championnat ben on espère quand même
voilà concrétiser ça puisque ça arrive
pas tous les ans et ni voilà dans son
parcours de sportive voilà avoir un
titre que ça soit à n'importe quel
niveau je pense que c'est une belle
récompense de l'investissement qu'on
peut donner donc être champion de France
certes en National 2 je pense que c'est
quand même voilà une sensation unique un
petit peu qu'on vit très peu au final he
dans une carrière de de oui voilà puis
même une montée rien que déjà une monté
c'est quelque chose qui se voilà il y a
peut-être une ou deux montées dans la
dans la carrière d'une sportive et donc
là avoir un titre de champion de France
je pense que ça serait vraiment
l'apothéose donc voilà on va tout faire
du moins pour pour y arriver et alors là
ça sera les derniers match avec vino
puisqu'il a annoncé samedi
officiellement qu'il allait qu'il allait
quitter le club ça c'est un peu une
déception du côté des joueuses Lilla
voilà qui qui s'en aille ou il vous aait
déjà prévenu un petit peu il nous avait
déjà prévenu mais c'est c'est
véritablement une déception parce que
enfin moi personnellement je suis au
club depuis 3 ans et depuis 3 ans vinco
gère équipe des filles du coup on s'est
un peu habitué on a nos petites
habitudes d'entraînement de coaching ou
l'entraîneur de l'équipe évidemment tout
à fait on avait juste oublié de de de le
préciser oui donc c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'il était làou c'était un projet
depuis 3 ans quand il est arrivé c'était
l'objectif du club de voilà de oui c'est
ça exactement et du coup bah on espère
vraiment remporter ce titre là et et
pour nous et pour lui
surtout finir vraiment sur un titre ce
serait vraiment et et justement euh vous
allez il va la suite c'est la nationale
une euh il y a une grosse marche de de
progression j'imagine entre les deux
divisions surtout éviter de faire
l'ascenseur voilà exactement ouais parce
que ça peut arriver arriver très vite
sans sans s'en rendre compte ça va être
compliqué de gérer ça en fait la
différence se niveau elle se joue pas
forcément au niveau t technique mais
c'est surtout au niveau des physiques
puisque donc les physiques donc les
joueux sont beaucoup plus grandes
beaucoup plus imposante euh le rythme
est beaucoup plus soutenu également
après en terme de technique on peut tout
à fait rivaliser avec avec ces joueuses
là mais c'est vrai que il y a une
dimension physique qui est un peu plus
importante qu'il va falloir bien
évidemment prendre en compte dans le
recrutement ou bien par rapport à notre
préparation pour ce championnat l'année
prochaine vous parlez recrutement
justement en termes financiers est-ce
qu'il y a un vrai palier aussi entre la
Nationale 2 la Nationale 1 c'est le cas
en tout cas chez les hommes en basket ce
qui explique aussi les difficult
difficultés pardon de de trappe le club
de basket de trappe qui pendant des
années a souhaité monter en National une
là cette fois-ci ils connaissent la
relenégation à l'issue de de de la
saison c'est plus compliqué euh au
niveau financier le club mettra les
moyens est-ce qu'il y a un palier en
tout cas euh alors là je peux pas vous
dire quel est le montant exigé pour la
nationale une mais évidemment ça suppose
des déplacements qui sont beaucoup plus
longs donc il faut partir le weekend il
faut se déplacer soit en train réserver
des chambres d'hôtel donc forcément même
en terme de frais de fonctionnement pour
l'arbitrage ça suppose beaucoup plus
d'investissements en tant que joueuse on
vous a assuré en tout cas que le club
mettrait les moyens oui ben de toute
façon c'était l'objectif depuis 3 ans
donc je pense qu'ils ont suffisamment
mis d'argent de côté voilà ou discutter
avec Philippe F qui est dirigeant à
l'entente le chîn Versailles samedi soir
il m'a dit que les renforts étaient
prévus pour évidemment en qualité mais
en quantité parce que vous n'êtes pas
beaucoup de joueus et voilà le projet
est là est établi donc le but c'est de
rester en National une comme il m'a dit
et voir voir plus haut après donc
rendez-vous pour les déjà la finale
parce que avant la nation il y a la
finale du championnat de France voilà il
y a un petit titre un beau titre on
espère que qu'il en reviendra 8 et 9
juin du côté de tour c'est ça voilà
c'est ça c'est exactement ça donc on
espère peut-être vous voir et puis
revenir également sur ce plateau pour
fêter le titre merci beaucoup à toutes
les quatre d'être venu ce soir et donc
rendez-vous le 8 et 9 pour ce futur
titre espérant merci beaucoup
merci wilfre nous allons passer à une
discipline plutôt inconnue ce weekend la
base de loisir allez un un petit quiz ce
weekend la base de loisirs de 50 ans
nine accueillé la 4e journée du
championnat de France de kayak polo
mélange comme son nom l'indique de
canoué kayak et de Water poo mais aussi
de handbal ce sport spectaculaire est en
pleine croissance en France et dans les
ilvines du côté de trappe et évidemment
cette ville essaie de tirer sa pagué du
jeu si je puis dire reportage découverte
réalisé avec Julie Rocha Soarez très en
forme Antony ce soir attention au kayak
polo il y a contact la mise en jeu
résume la discipline en plus d'être un
bon kayquiste le poloï doit être
explosif endurant et surtout à droit
avec le ballon deux équipes de C joueurs
s'affrontent sur un plan d'au d'une
trentaine de mètres pendant deux
périodes de 10 minutes ils peuvent se
passer le ballon à la main ou à la
paguet et même dribler c'est un peu
commeand où tous les joueurs sont à la
fois défenseurs et à la fois attaquants
après chacun a ses ses préférences et
ses positions on a des comm on a des
ailiés en général les aés ce sont les
plus rapides et les centraux c'est
plutôt les les gars les plus costauds
ceux qui tiennent bien leur bateau qui
sont bien costaud quoi arrivé en France
en 1984 le kayak polo est un vrai sport
de contact à tout moment le porteur de
balle peut-être poussé à l'eau par
l'adversaire c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
aspects les plus spectaculaires de la
discipline qui fait des poloistes et
spécialistes de l'esquimot ex technique
permettant de remettre le bateau à
l'endroit en quelques secondes ça peut
être violent oui on a des casques à
grille donc il y a des coups de paguet
parfois assez rarement sur le visage
mais bon même un ballon sur le nez ça
fait pas de bien mais c'est vrai que
c'est un jeu très très physique on a des
bateaux adaptés avec des mousses à
l'avant à l'arrière des gilets renforcés
sur les côtés qui permettent de nous
protéger de les côtes cette saison 80
équipes pratique le kayak polo dans
l'Hexagone de son côté Trapp se bat pour
son maintien en National 4